leute heute abend beginnt war wofür ich
bin mit luca zusammen im team und wir
haben ziemlich keine ahnung was wir
machen sollen ich würde sagen wir rufen
jetzt erst mal an und besprechen uns was
wir überhaupt machen
max hallo was geht heißt es wichtig war
heute abend ist es heute abend ist heute
abend ja denkmal du bist genau so gut
vorbereitet wie ich ja ich hatte gerade
eigentlich noch zu tun aber habe ich
auch nachher machen was gibt wer sowieso
an also was los zuerst
ich dachte mir einfach wir müssen
irgendwas machen weil warum ein
wir sind beide nicht mehr so die die
größten groß in minecraft und irgendwas
müssen wir unseren zuschauern bieten nun
ich habe mir da so ein paar gedanken was
hast du dir dann da überlegt was man
machen könnte was hältst du von der idee
dass wir jede einzelne ware folge eine
andere talent machte er wie wie niemals
dass jede einzelne folge machen wir
irgendwas anderes gegenseitig sage ich
mal genauer um das ganze ein bisschen
aufzupeppen weil wir wahrscheinlich bei
den top ten sind machen wir zum beispiel
jetzt in der ersten folge wenn ich du
wäre oder so was du willst jetzt in der
ersten folge wenn ich du wäre challenge
machen
safe oder meinst du bist zu groß für die
erste folge also ich bin dabei ich würde
sagen dann sehen wir uns jetzt eben game
wieder und dann machen wir das jetzt mal
gleich alles klar
12 sekunden später wir sind jetzt in
gern meine damen und herren warum
beginnen sie in sekunden man ja ok
besprochen unserer block ab haut ab in
den wald rennen
und erstmal erstmal denn erstmal renn
renn renn opa direkt mir hinterher ja ja
gamers teams hinter uns echt neben wir
quasi okay dann waren die direkt holzer
panholzer papst keine gute idee direkt
heute zum kapitän lukas schnell du
kannst und ein gestänge stecken so
anspannung vor meine damen und herren
okay da man merkt dass ich länger nicht
minecraft gespielt hat erst ein schwert
und jetzt vorsicht schnieken des niveaus
liegen wir brauchen essen am anfang so
folgt mir mal okay war schwang ist da
leute wie ist da wo anspannung ist da
ich dachte kopf nicht mehr gerade aber
wir laufen jetzt geschickt und ihn
einfach über die bäume
du machst wenn ich du wäre vor zehn
liegestütze mag ist das laut junge
folgen wie folgt nicht folgen die fakten
hyper wo bist du neben mir okay wir
gehen jetzt wird vorsichtig vorsichtig
vorsichtig vorsichtig wir brauchen dich
am anfang auf jeden fall essen wo bist
du ich nicht gut aber nach meinem namen
da bist du ja schön da bist wirklich
okay so folgten momente voller name von
techniken wir gehen wieder auf die
vorausgegangene folgt mir folgt mir sind
die blitze werde auch so laut das kannst
du gleich ändern noch aber erst müssen
wir schauen dass leute tut mir leid wäre
würde ich zehn liegestütze machen ist es
jetzt sein herz gerade jetzt macht sie
nie gestützt junge wir sind noch
direkter nähe von spawn wenn einer kommt
was kann sie nicht ich kann euch nicht
hören du kannst nicht okay okay ich
mache das jetzt ganz schnell leute das
macht nämlich 1 unsere ware taktik wir
machen challenges direkt während der ob
mein gott da ist in münchen das ist dass
münchens riecht an max arschloch als gut
ja ich hab so angst gab gerade
stellt euch jetzt mal hast du dich dabei
gefilmt ich habe dabei gefilmt ok ich
werde mich etwa kurz einig dass bei max
außer ich werde dich ich werde es mir so
zurückgeben
ich hoffe da unten folgen wir folglich
folgen ja ok dass ein hase trügen also
erstmals erde gehen oder so ja wir haben
auch noch ein bisschen holz auf jeden
fall dass man machen bisschen häuser und
vielleicht mal ein schwert erstmal auf
jeden fall ein bisschen holz das nur
unter die erde gehen ja ein bisschen
angst über der erde hier gerade hier
kommen wir suchen uns eine höhle folgt
mir mal scheint auch das heute überhaupt
nur zwei sticks wie holz und essen ist
am anfangs wichtigste kommt mit visum
und natürliche höhle möglich sein
bordeaux carrasso ich weiß gar nicht ob
ich noch warten sollte bis wir unter der
erde sind mit deiner challenge was ist
der manager doch sagt margot folgen wenn
du mich schon so körperlich verausgaben
lassen willst dann will ich sagen lieber
luca machte nochmals ins zittern
warte bei mir ist es ganz viel zu laut
mit dem letztlich muss gleich unbedingt
mal umstellen
okay aber wie machen sie das mal gedacht
kannst du mich hören das ist für mich
aber kurz ich fühle mich auch dabei was
inters tabs woher kommt folgen wir
erstmal folgen erst mal wir hatten ja
auch erstmal ab in die höhle ok deshalb
sofort eine zinszuschlag deshalb wir
würden uns hier gegen 60
ich brauche gar nicht mehr sprinten ich
auch nicht ich auch nicht das heißt
gespenst einer finte dann sind die
richtige art hier soll welche weil hier
wurde es abgebaut
oh ja da wurde holz abgebaut
nein einen baum doch okay du kannst der
haut samtweich mal
wir gehen ja wir brauchen neue taktik
jetzt mal ja wir lieber wir machen uns
jetzt erstmal auf ok dann skelette
gewöhnen uns töten
liga wir können nicht also ich kann
sprinten wieder okay folgen jetzt dass
man hier runter bringen ist hier ein so
ein paar jahren wieder rein
apple werden extrem von 10.000 lassen
dafür
okay ich habe er darüber gesetzt jetzt
mache ist ja irgendwie 10
aber ich darf ja ich muss ja auf der
taste bleiben wir für eine tasse zum
snacken halten
das habe ich auch gehört ist nicht ob
ich mache jetzt darf ich will mir nicht
mehr sicher was it up sind aber ich
fühle mich mal dabei ok ich hoffe dass
einige leute ich mache jetzt sehen
setups also los geht's wir sind so dumm
jungen es ist walter was machen wir hier
[Musik]
da hast du deine 10 setup uns nirgends
nicken bei seinem gott gott gott nein
das kann spaß
okay das erstmal ein schock hat uns
raten ein bisschen essen gebraten
hast du noch hast du noch holz max
ich bin s bahn zu nutzen ich bin jetzt
nicht fertig aber ich hatte gerade echt
ein schock meines lebens war ich
irgendwie einen namen gesehen habe
weicheier sind will ich sagen max du
antwortest mir jetzt immer im chat das
heißt wenn ich irgendwas frage wenn ich
diese frage stelle man wolltest du im
chat genau in den nächsten 60 sekunden
wachs wie geht's dir denn leute ihr
müsst jetzt mal auf den chat unten
achten
könntest du mir mal das wort vollidiot
buchstabieren
[Musik]
ich weiß gar nicht was machst du
eigentlich gerade was ist das beste team
und war
davis gestoppt das ipad wie komm endlich
das ist junge jeder liest jeder
zuschauer heute helfe gerade so viele
leute auf dem server und marc schreibt
einfach in den chat voll die tiere als
ob dein ernst geht so dirr vollidiot
essen braten reitmeier du schreibst
jetzt luca entschuldigt einen
wunderschönen teampartner max ich habe
ihnen verleitet das zu schreiben wenn
ich nur wäre würde ich das schreiben
entschuldigt meine wunderschönen
teampartner max ich habe ihn dazu
verleitet was zu schreiben
es ist schreiben ging nicht mehr
also ich hab freigeschossen abgebaut was
soll das ja wir gehen wieder in die
natürliche würde münster also ich habe
mich hingesetzt
es gibt auf jeden fall schon viele tot
ich glaube dass du ja locker schon sechs
sieben leute gestorben oder so
es regnet das heißt mops ja das heißt
allerdings macht da vorne waren relativ
großen krieg war da vorne waren
natürliche höhle dass osama hingehen und
dabei wie gesagt essen mit einem essen
mit dem essen mitnehmen können wir erst
am anfang nicht genug vom frieden
geschaffen er ja alles gut
du magst wie stelle ich jetzt die
allerdings aus die blitze du musst
options sounds und dann irgendwie okay
als wetterschutz beschützen
ok ich wünsche zu löschen sounds of jazz
musik und geräusche dann wetter einfach
runter drehen
okay wer da habe ich jetzt ausgemacht
promis ist voll okay story leute daran
habe ich jetzt überhaupt nicht gedacht
vorher aber maxi rechts ein hühnchen
guter start würde ich sagen das ist echt
krass dass wir noch leben
vor allem ich würde mal behaupten die
ausgangslage ist nicht schlecht es gibt
halt immer in der ersten folge schon
über die kranken menschen die
okay ist krone also nicht wie hast du
noch ein holz ja da platzt ihr mal hin
den kräftig table warten wir das ding
einfach ich halte ihn derzeit ausschaut
wer ist jetzt dran wenn ich nur wäre ich
bin dran und zwar sage ich direkt wenn
ich du wäre würde ich einfach mal unsere
koordinaten in dem schreiben
aber ich will dort bis wir die krone hat
gefordert waren für mich eigentlich
komplett beherrschen luca l wird obwohl
witzig wenn wir die kohle abgebaut haben
schreibt mag es einfach mal unsere
koordinaten den chat weil das seine wenn
nicht nur ihre aufgabe die leute was
haltet ihr eigentlich davon dass wir
dieses wenn ich du wäre machen weil ich
schreibe dir nicht mit uns wir haben es
einfach vorher gesagt ja wir haben jetzt
keine riesigen chance das ding zu
gewinnen wir haben jetzt nicht die ultra
zeit das ganze über wochen hinweg zu
ziehen weil wir beide bisschen ich habe
angst ich habe ersten gegeben kommt
nimmst du da war noch kohle riesiges
loch ticker kommt die chance unsere hin
nicht welche die wärme wasser warum so
habt ihr wasser lieben uhr sollte jetzt
was folgt mir ist mich verarschen die
aus einzelaktion von trainer reiner
einer möglichen in die quote damit ob
leute jetzt haben leute unsere
kürzlichen behalten ab sofort liegen du
hast nicht vergessen legte auf akita ich
nicht die ganze zeit nicht scheiße
das war die dümmste wenn ich tue ihre
aufgabe aller zeiten überhaupt ist aber
nicht über die ablöse bieten sofort tot
hast du noch holz ich hab ja hier
erwarte moment ich baue mir eben kurz
das ding hier abgeben
splatter sie auch was machen kann der
gleichen zeit
ja hier du kannst du kräftig table
machen ihm steht ist gestorben neun von
selbst schreibt mal unter jetzt bist du
ja nicht dran opfer opfer richtig so
jetzt schreibt du mal bitte in städten
als eheleute max bordell oder das ist
der blitz ist dass der blitz als
erschreckt mich doch nicht so sehr da
war gerade irgendwas ohne spaß leute ich
werde euch jetzt aber die szene ein was
da vorne gesehen habe da war irgendwas
max ich weiß nicht ob ich gerade
eingeblendet ich darf hier nicht richtig
klappen max brät da vorne hat uns reisen
ja okay lass mal anfangen rüstung zu
machen du hast keine kohle reingepackt
ich habe noch keinen gehabt du hast du
finden coole gefragt ob ich habe der
kohle reingepackt er lasst uns erst mal
eisen schwert machen max wir gehen auf
jeden fall mal ein bisschen weiter rein
erstmal ein bisschen weiter rein in die
höhle ja nimmst du das da vorne mit alle
ja ich hab alles geholt
ok ich mir eben die ohnehin noch auf
jeden fall
bitte schreiben chat als achter offen
bitte schreib in chat sorry dass luca
beleidigend wurde war seine aufgabe ist
auch so schreibt julian chatt opfer
richtig so
wir sind beide auf 5 live dabei
hast du ein crafting table max ja ich
habe mir heute zu es ist einfach so eine
schande dass wir gut leben weil ich hab
mir ist es so eine schande dass wir
leben und sternchen zukunft so ist das
schwert hinter dir und wer dich von ihm
stehe und empfahl einfach so gestorben
mit meinem kampf was geht da ab
keine ahnung aber noch mehr heißen lasst
uns direkt richtung machen mit
übelriechender leben hier habe man bis
einfach die dem autor rüstungsteile
sache okay was für rüstungs zeit und
erstes und einfachen panisch kann am
meisten protektion das heißt harnisch
brustpanzer ja dann können wir aber nur
ein machen ja egal ich meine spieler
noch mehr gefahren
okay wir sind aber auch demnächst einmal
bei 15 minuten
das heißt wir werden dann aber
automatisch schon geklickt wir haben
hast du noch essen eigentlich ja ich
habe es im gefühl welches also gebraten
ist meine hilfe
ich habe alles gegeben von mir gerade
mal hast du noch gebratenes gebranntes
eisen leider nicht nur 15 minuten sind
sogar gleich schon vorbei glaube ich ein
paar sekunden 9 uhr sollte das hier eben
die zu bauen werden klicken ich glaube
nicht vor ja wir können ja mal ganz gut
so ein bisschen provisorisch machen
sicherheitshalber dass wir nicht
unbedingt so alles zugebaut jedoch ruhig
sagen was erfolgreiche erste folge oder
maxxim alles raus auf den höfen ein
gegner ist zunahmen das spiel zu
verlassen
mister x ist hier die müssen in der nähe
sein
hast du magst ich hab das eisen okay
kommt
vorsicht folgt die wand rein
aber das kommt zu mir kommt mir geweckt
reisen mitnehmen
nimmst du das eisen noch eben mit ja
hast du noch irgendwelche rüstung wie
machen kannst dass wir uns noch
währenddessen gegriffen
ich habe 77 eisen okay ich hab grad
perfekt alter gar nicht erkennt man
nicht wo wir uns hin gebaut haben aber
warum nicht benutzen aber die zeit und
fahren ein bisschen weiter sagen danke
an dieser stelle kategorie schon mal
direkt kind ja ich glaube in europa zwei
oder so hey ich kann überhaupt nicht
richtig kommentieren nicht findet kann
total komisch dass er bei uns ist ja das
ist richtig komisch du sagst du das
letzte gerade hinter uns kann nichts
jetzt hinter und khalid da kommen welche
davon welche luca vorsicht zurück ok go
und rotherbaum butterbrot aber wunderbar
rein und dann die sagt okay okay comco
komplette die alten blöcke hinten ja ich
seit sich alle noch mal runter noch mal
runter du hast du angst um unsere seite
alter was wieso sind sie dabei und sie
kann das sein
ich glaube jetzt ist dürfen wir ein
wenig absichern
ich gehe noch mal runter nicht
auffliegen alter die am hut bist du oben
bleibt oben nicht auch heute selber und
ich brauche ich wollte ich wollte konnte
damit du nicht aufhörst es nicht
eigentlich sollten wir safe sein
ich meine wir können uns ja nicht
aussagen von selbst folgen noch mal kann
ich das ja okay wir haben die theorie
blöcke hinter und setzten hermacht dass
irgendwas mit dem weg in die andere
richtung auch so ein bisschen ja
irgendwas was wir öffnen alter wie krank
ist das gerade was die sind immer noch
nah bei uns ja und kommt kommst du mir
runter wo ich gerade bin
eine spitzhacke geht nicht natürlich
seien einfach nebeneinander unter bauern
okay wir können nicht lieber nimmt
direkt die nächste folge aufpasst
okay fragt was wir müssen wir ganz
überlegen wir kommen immer noch nicht
raus wir können immer nicht aus nein
wenn ich springe sieht man dann trotzdem
einen namen
die waschen wenn du da nächstes das kein
problem okay gut entfalten okay wir
machen jetzt genau nach jetzt folgendes
du brauchst dich nehmen wir einfach
gerade runter firma max ich muss erst
mal hatte ich habe keine spitzhacke
nenne ich bin ich bin runter hilft
darunter brüche gegangen ist der hund
einfach bisschen runter warte noch nicht
ich wurde ich bin direktor bei mir kommt
immer noch ein gegner ist oder ok ich
bin vom server jetzt okay ich bin runter
u
junge junge junge war es das wird
richtig krass noch zum ende gerade wenn
ich du wäre möglichst fc deutschland nur
lesen
alter schwede
ich bin so froh kann wo hast du die
gesehen wie wir haben gesehen
damit die anderen den anderen spieler
ich kannte ich hab sie kann hier die
partikel zeigen man hat schon die blöcke
gesehen die sie abgebaut haben und wir
haben es dadurch gerettet dass wir so
unscheinbare blöcke wie eisen oder sonst
was ihr mann hätten wir koppel genommen
denn ihr tot gewesen
ja ich glaube und egal leute das ist auf
jeden fall unser wahrer konzept wir
machen immer die ja immer verschiedene
challenges in jeder folge riese folge
wasser die wenn ich du wäre challenge
und wer mal zwischendurch wirklich
einmal unsere koordinaten gezeigt
deswegen haben jetzt wahrscheinlich auch
gefunden oder angesehen ist in der nähe
waren also es war schon nervenkitzel pur
schaltet auf jeden fall wieder die
zweite folge eines erfolge die kommen
nämlich morgen aus den kanälen von max
und mir da seht ihr dann ob sie uns nach
scheunen ob es dann zu einem kampf kommt
und sonst bewährte nicht vergessen und
ich würde sagen die letzten wort
invertieren markt
machs gut und junge wir leben noch
[Musik]